how are you i'm good carlos thank you
very much for coming how are you
doing very well you know i gotta say
watching this series over the past
little while you and alan arkin together
has just it's been perfection
um did it feel strange without him
like moving forward with the show
without him
sure yeah yeah though yeah it's just
you know always going to be yeah
probably yes
but um you know i mean life goes on you
know alan
allen felt i think the show was
originally contracted for two years
and uh you know it's it's a fast-paced
television schedule and everything
alan's a few years older than i am
i think it was a tough you know tough
schedule so he he did it but
but i'm very happy but yeah he was
certainly nervous and you start off the
third season with alan harkin's funeral
uh and we get gotta get a few laughs out
of that
and you go from there but you're not
it's not what you expect but i was happy
how the third season turned out
yeah and lots of amazing stories still
to tell kathleen turner
um when we saw her in season two
i know a lot of people were thinking god
i hope this happens more
and now here she is what was it like
picking up with her and
um working those scenes with her
effortless effortless it's just you know
it's
obviously a lot of good memories i
couldn't believe it was 31 years since
we did
uh uh the war of the roses
um but she was perfect even last year
when chuck was talking about where the
the show was heading and he wanted to
get give me this ex-wife and
we talked about kathleen and you know
she was just be great
so this is just a comfort factor when
you've worked with somebody
before three times to be the fourth time
you just are much easier with each other
it's it's much more pleasant
when you're making those moments happen
for screen does it happen
during rehearsal or do you wait until
the camera's rolling like do you do you
save some surprises for that time
i mean it it depends but no you
you know i mean look we are we are
blessed by chuck laurie we have
wonderful scripts everything
the writing is is excellent so
if you're halfway smart you just open
your mouth and say the words
they say and uh and and don't fall down
you you'll be okay because that's how
good the writing
the the writing is so you know
we we just we just feel the comfort
factor you just feel
the overlapping is much easier you can
step on each other's lines a little bit
nobody's offended
um and uh but you're not saving it up no
you don't save it up for the big day
you try to see what you can get before
you get there see
how much you can squeeze out i think one
of the
exciting things for fans when they saw
the trailer was seeing that morgan
freeman is going to be involved in
season three
what was it like um bringing him aboard
that was a treat that was totally uh
chuck's doing i mean i've worked with
morgan before
and i didn't know he'd done a couple of
tweets that he was a he was a fan of the
show
but man when when he came in and did it
was just great
and i really got to keep for the for the
the kids my acting
my acting actors by acting students you
know but they all were like
morgan friedman so uh it was great but
we've been very
fortunate with the show and having a
number of uh
uh guest stars coming in people that
would not normally be on a half hour
comedy show but just really liked the
show like the writing
and so it's picked up this this this
rhythm that i think has helped make the
show so special
i'm sure a lot of people are gonna miss
the show after season three is
all said and done um do you feel like
that's all that's it for sandy's story
it's the right time to finish the story
yeah yeah i wanted to go on for a third
season just to sort of tie this story
together
but i think now we've got a very clear
picture as to
what happened with sandy and where he's
going and
and what's going on and we kind of deal
with all the other all the other
characters you know and the marriage of
my daughter
to paul sarah baker's
part and paul reiser both wonderful
actors
uh so it's the time the time is is right
um
given it so i'm i've i've enjoyed i can
walk away and
like like a very good marriage and
thank all the parties involved